don schula passed on
monday at the age of 90 chris sims
that's how we get started on this
tuesday edition of pft live
one of the all-time
great figures one of the stalwarts of
the nfl the all-time winningest coach
back-to-back super bowl titles turned
around to miami dolphins team and that
implies there was ever a right direction
for miami dolphins they were never
anything until he arrived in 1969 and
just in his third season had them in the
super bowl that's an amazing kind of
turnaround that's an amazing turnaround
by today's standards back then it took
at least five years to get a team out of
the weeds just amazing what don shula
accomplished both with the colts and
then with the dolphins and a sad day for
the national football league with the
passing of one of the true all-time
one-of-a-kind greats
yeah uh it really is a sad day for
anybody who loves football because don
shula's
the hierarchy i mean the the pantheon of
all-time great coaches he's he's in that
conversation we know belichick lombardi
landry noel walsh schuller of course and
shula you know he's right up there with
the best of them but you know the career
as far as with the baltimore colts how
special that run was some of the great
players he coached over the year
over the years i mean the fact that he
coached johnny unitas and dan marino and
they were there was a large gap in
between their careers just tells you the
sustained greatness he had as a coach
the vision the ability to
change with the times mike like we've
seen with so many other good coaches so
uh it is a sad day icon and uh
you know just one of those guys mike
i'll never forget just that tan with
those sunglasses on the sideline and a
teal blue sweater
i'll always picture him looking like
that roaming the sidelines
the team issued a statement following
his passing on monday don schuller was
the patriarch of the miami dolphins for
50 years he brought the winning edge to
our franchise and put the dolphins in
the city of miami in the national sports
scene our deepest thoughts and prayers
go out to marianne his spouse along with
his children dave donna sharon ann and
mike and you know when i think of don
schula and he coached against george
halas that's how long he was in the nfl
from george halas all the way to bill
belichick
don schula
is as integral to the dolphins as george
halas was
to the bears now george hallas owned the
bears but
you know they'll surely wear the
initials dfs for donald francis schuler
this year in miami but i almost feel
like schuler is big enough to the
dolphins that it should be perpetual
like the gsh that we have seen on the
sleeves of the bears for the past 35
plus years chris sure
yeah you know mike that it's a good
point and i agree with you you know i
think this is the
the type of person that just exemplifies
the great history of the nfl and you
know further to your point with the
miami dolphins i mean
you know yes it's it's synonymous with
don shula when i think miami dolphins
that's the first guy i think of i think
of those 70s teams and larry zonka being
undefeated
um so he you know the fact that he went
from the baltimore colts where you know
they were viewed as the best team in
football the best team in the nfl won a
championship there of course had that
crush crushing super bowl loss in super
bowl three to the jets but then to just
go to miami like you said earlier and
almost instantaneously make them at
power within the nfl uh that was
remarkable i mean to go to three
straight super bowls in the early 70s
and be on the you know the undefeated 72
team you know sandwiched in between the
three super bowl appearances and winning
super bowl two and you know the second
and third appearance there
yeah i'm with you mike i mean that's you
should have his initials on the jersey
maybe a decal on
on their helmet forever he he is the
miami dolphins
and i misspoke earlier and i'm gonna
blame it on the fact that the season
happens in one year and the super bowl
happens in the next year but the bottom
line is this it was his second season
with the dolphins that he took them to
the super bowl not not thorough
in season two with the miami dolphins
they went to the super bowl lost to the
cowboys and then
became a team that lost the super bowl
and then that sparked the 17-0 season
and how many years went by before
another team was able to lose the super
bowl and turn around and win it the next
year it was the patriots after losing
super bowl 52 winning super bowl 53
that's how long it was that's how hard
it is to do what he did
like it was nothing right he laid the
foundation for greatness in miami
immediately took them to a super bowl
yeah okay i lost again because look the
one footnote on his career is he was the
coach of the colts when they lost to the
jets in super bowl three i think he more
than made up for that but to to go oh
and two in the super bowl initially as
he said in his hall of fame speech it's
very easy for that to perpetuate and to
get out and not get out of that that rut
and to turn it around the way they did
with true perfection one of the things
larry zonka said yesterday to reporters
about don schuler
zonka resented shula's ways more often
than not until he saw
what shula's ways did in 1972
and when you go undefeated and win the
super bowl adhering to
very focused determined high
expectations from your coach
that gets the guys to buy in and zonka
bought in at that point he understood he
got it he realized that there was a
method to the madness of the coach who
drove and drove and pushed and and tried
to get the absolute most out of his
players i mean that's what any good
coach does and shula did it
yeah that's right i mean when you're a
player you forget sometimes and you tell
you take it personal you know but then
it's one of those things once you step
back or somebody older and wiser
explains it to you or maybe your career
is over you realize man that guy was
just he was pushing all my buttons to
make me the best i could possibly be i
mean don chula certainly had that effect
the fact that you know went to super
bowls in three different decades and you
know like we've already mentioned the
quick turnaround from the colts to the
miami dolphins and the dolphins being so
relevant in the 70s and then really to
start the 80s extremely relevant once
again you know go to the super bowl in
1982 the strike shortened season and
lose to the redskins you know oh okay oh
yep hey we need a new quarterback oh hey
dan marino's here i can change with the
times we'll be the biggest best throwing
football team in all of all of the nfl
you know the 70s he wins with smash
mouth running football the 80s all of a
sudden it's dan marino in the
high-flying show and then you know was
also competitive in the early 90s you
know before he finally retired and got
out so just a an amazing long stretch of
a career and to be that relevant that
long and be able to change your style of
plays and be able to adjust to the
players over the years and how they
change because we know they change
decade decade to decade i think it just
speaks to how smart he was the vision he
had on the football field and most
importantly the person he was and the
people skills he had to be able to
adjust to all these people all you know
all through the years
well one name of a former don schuler
great quarterback that came up a lot in
january was bob griese because
that's how the 49ers were winning
playoff games with the quarterback doing
right bare minimum hardly throwing the
ball at all and to go from that in the
early 70s to dan marino in the mid 80s
that epitomizes the idea that you take
what you have
and you make it work with what you have
when you have and and the rules
influence that as well obviously but
when you have
a gunslinger like dan marino when you've
got
mark clayton and mark duper on the
outside that's what you cater to when
you've got larry zonka jim kick and
mercury morris and you can just run the
ball down the throats of any defense
that you face then that's what you focus
on that's what coaching is whatever your
team is
you take those guys and you make it work
and mourinho told a story yesterday
that
he never met don shula before he was
drafted i don't think he even spoke to
him before shula called and picked him
because mourinho had that free fall in
1983. and the dolphins
the one team that realized we may have
something here with this kid let's take
this kid from pittsburgh and bring him
to miami and i guess some parallels
because don shula was an ohio guy he
wasn't a florida guy he had they had
nothing to do with florida until he
became the dolphins coach in 1970 so you
know there was that kinship right out of
the gates and it worked right out of the
gates and shula knew hey
i'm going to have
passing numbers i've never had before
because i have a guy like i've never had
before except for john united but that
was a different time different place
different era but still to to get the
most out of it that's what unites would
have been in the 80s that's what
mourinho was 80s but that's what bob
griese was never going to be able to be
in the 70s
yeah that's you know yes you know and of
course you know you got johnny united a
little bit towards the end of his career
but it does it just it's it's amazing
when you think about the 70s dolphins
and you know i'm the kind of kid and and
still to this day that goes back and
watches super bowl memories and old
super bowl games and you know season
long stories about the 72 73 dolphins or
whatever it may be you know it just the
fact that he
won in the 70s with run game defense and
then in the 80s you know to stay
relevant like they did and of course win
the afc used to be in the afc playoffs a
whole lot had some great battles with
the the buffalo bills towards the end of
the 80s decade and all that you know
just to change your your your genre
around mike i think again it just speaks
to all the great things uh don shula was
as a person and a coach because you're
right you know he just took whatever oh
these are the ingredients okay we're
going to make it happen and work and you
know they were still very competitive
and a pain in the butt uh and amazing
too when you really think about the 80s
because
all i think about is dan marino on the
offense and some of those super bowl
teams they went to i'm not even sure i
can like right now i'll choke i can't
remember some of the defensive players
on those teams because i don't think
they were great defenses or any
household names at that point that i
could sit here and say oh yeah man he
had that defense the line you know laid
back with in case mourinho wasn't on
fire no it was all about the offense and
mourinho out shooting you know out
shooting out people
out shootouts
shootout people but i think the defense
back in those days was the killer bees
the killer bees in the early 80s chiming
in on twitter it was the killer bees
defense because so many of the players
on that defense had a last name that
started with b sometimes hilarious
nickname is really that simple we got a
lot of bow campers and whatnot and here
all right it's the killer bees so uh
there was just something and see for me
i discovered football
right at the time
that the dolphins were going 17-0 for me
the moment that i understood that the
nfl was a big deal was the immaculate
reception game december 20 1972. i've
told that story before about how the
game was blacked out and the town i grew
up in because it was 60 miles from
pittsburgh and back in those days the
game was blacked out within 75 miles
even if it was sold out and it was so we
picked up a signal from outside the
bubble we were the only house in the
neighborhood that had it the house was
full of people everybody went nuts when
franco harris made the catch the next
week the steelers lost to the dolphins
in the afc championship game because
that was the year the dolphins went 17-0
the dolphins were the team that year and
chris back in those days
you didn't earn home field advantage in
the postseason it was a rotation the
steelers actually hosted the dolphins in
the afc championship game one of the
most unfair outcomes you can imagine
because the dolphins were undefeated and
they had to go to pittsburgh in january
to play the uh or late december that's
how the schedule worked at the time they
had to go to pittsburgh in late december
to play the steelers but won that game
and then two weeks later beat washington
in super bowl seven but that the
dolphins just dominated that i mean it
went from the dolphins to the steelers
and the cowboys and the raiders those
were the four teams that ran roughshod
rough shop rough shot over the nfl in
the early 70s and one of the reasons why
pete roselle hated it pete roselle
wanted parody today's nfl although you
could argue especially with the patriots
today's nfl is a lot like the nfl in the
70s but today's nfl was born of the
frustration that people who ran the
sport felt because it was always the
same teams that were in the mix for a
championship and there were so many
other teams out there that were just
like what are we doing here well we
can't compete with these teams
yeah well
yes
you know those dolphins teams you know
first off the immaculate reception thing
i think that's amazing because so many
people don't realize that that you know
everyone i think thinks the steelers
made that catch and went on to win the
super bowl uh it is a cool tidbit to
know that the dolphins shattered that
dream just a week later but you know
with don schula and you know all the
great coaches and the teams he had to
deal with in the early 70s too when you
just think about the cowboys the
steelers the raiders the afc was of
course really competitive at that time
uh i i just uh i'm amazed about the
longevity the consistency you know and
mike i mean where do where do you put
him and the all-time great coaches you
know where is he like i i understand
he's at the very very top we're talking
cream of the crop conversation here but
when you think like hallows lombardi you
know
shula landry no i mean and belichick i
mean it's it's it's really that that
short with bill walsh may be thrown in
there too i i don't know if there's any
other names that come out you know as
far as to me as far as the cream of the
crop
greatest head coaches we've ever seen in
the sport there's probably a few i'm
missing there but he's certainly in that
conversation with with the house and
lombardi's and belichick's
the biggest difference and i would boil
it down
to
schuler and belichick
when you talk about longevity when you
talk about victory she's still the
all-time wise coach at 328 although
belichick should catch that number
within the next few years if he
continues to coach there was a time
where belichick said he wouldn't coach
past 70. well when you're staring 70 in
the face you have a different attitude i
think about about things you previously
said about how long you planned to coach
but even if belichick catches him i mean
shula to have 33 years chris and only
have two losing seasons belichick can't
say that right um no
and and maybe he'll get the 33 years but
we'd have to go back and look i mean he
had losing seasons with the browns he
had a losing season to start his career
with the patriots the years that they
haven't made the playoffs i think in
2002 they were eight and eight and then
2008 they were 11 and five and somehow
didn't make the past because the
dolphins ended up winning the division
that year but uh i i think that shula
now here's the big difference and we got
to be fair to the way football operates
today sure it's a hell of a lot harder
to hold your team together now than it
was back in the 70s once you got that
nucleus of great players you kept them
although don schula did have guys like
larry zonka and mercury morris defect to
the wfl
if you even heard of the wfl look it up
on google not now wait until after the
show the wfl was one of these alternate
football leagues back in the early 70s
the first one to really give the nfl a
run for its money and it swiped larry
zonka away from the dolphins
yeah i i had no idea i mean i did never
heard that ever in my life so and that's
uh shocking to me but i yeah that that's
a new one to me but you're right i mean
it was a different age then but it
doesn't matter you know he still built a
nucleus and there is something to be
said about that there really is i mean
yeah to go from the baltimore colts who
were a power and foot you know the nfl
what he had built there you know they
were building a dynasty there wanna won
the nfl championship right uh and then
of course i know lost super bowl three
but had something sustainable you know
and of course the colts went to the
super bowl with super bowl five uh
against the dallas cowboys not long
after shula left so you know it showed
you what he built there and then of
course to build it basically three
different times with the miami dolphins
uh it is it is amazing to be able to do
it that long and that is not an easy job
being a head coach in the nfl man you're
on call 24 7. it's a grind and it's a
lot of different characters you got to
deal with and he dealt with him as good
as anybody we've ever seen and i'll miss
his tan smiling face that's for sure let
me just add this little post script for
those who are wondering what in the hell
the wfl was
it was a league that lasted for just a
season or two but actually managed to
get zonka gym kick
and receiver paul warfield away from the
dolphins to play for
the toronto
northmen if you and chris if you've
never heard of the wfl you never heard
of the toronto northmen the wwf did not
last long hey look they almost got ken
stabler away from the raiders that's how
competitive they were from a financial
standpoint because back in those days
you didn't have free agency the players
didn't have leverage when your contract
expired with your team
you were free to sign another contract
or not play that was it so it was a lot
easier to hold a team together except
when the wfl came along and don chula
had to deal with that but not the kind
of issues that bill belichick deals with
when you see players leave almost every
year still shula truly one of the
all-time greats truly uh a name that
would be
i don't know if there's an overall nfl
mount rushmore we've talked about mount
rushmores for different teams different
positions different eras
i don't know if you do
four figures all time in the national
football league how do you not put shula
on there with george hallace the other
two spots would be open for debate but
but i really do mean it i think the
dolphins do need to consider some sort
of a perpetual i agree the raiders the
raiders have it without davis yeah the
bears have it with george hallas and
even though shulin never owned the team
that's how significant he was to that
franchise and hopefully they'll give
that proper consideration that it's more
than just a one-year
honor that uh that the dolphins paid in
the memory of don schull
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports